les sourires sont au rendez vous cet été
à amboise la ville fait le plein à
commencer par son château le mois de
juillet en bois qui se passe plutôt bien
nous en tout cas au château d'amboise on
a une fréquentation qui est en hausse
par rapport à l'année de référence qui
était l'année 2018 par rapport à juillet
2008 on est à peu près 1 9 % d'entrées
payantes en plus donc c'est quand même
significatif et suite à ces deux années
conduite c'est quand même quelque chose
de très rassurant pour pour l'activité
du château les touristes étrangers sont
de retour en masse ils représentent 40 %
des visites de la forteresse avec en
plus le développement de la loire à vélo
tout roule pour les loueurs de cycle le
bilan est satisfaisant c'est bon dans
l'ensemble retour des étrangers
américains
on est un peu tôt mais ça pareil à la
voir avec les tournées de vide en plus
des américains les brésiliens italiens
espagnols allemands ou encore belge en
pince pour la ville royale les deux
années comme il semble donc bien loin
même si certaines nouvelles habitudes
des vacanciers semble parti pour rester
une nouvelle façon de voyager de
nouvelles façons de travailler parce
qu'avant on avait des tables coller
comme un pari coude à coude là on peut
plus remettre les tables comme avant
même qu'on est loin mais les gens ne
veulent plus et veulent l'intimité
qu'ils ont eue d'avant donc ça nous fait
perdre de la place mais les gens restent
plus longtemps les genres et consomment
plus les gens sont heureux
l'inflation n'a visiblement pas refroidi
les envies de vacances à amboise il faut
dire que la météo ensoleillée haybes et
ça tombe bien le beau temps ne devrait
pas quitter le val de loire avant un
moment